Vsauce happy almost Halloween to
celebrate I'm going to show you my top
six favorite flash games to get me into
the Halloween spirit and you can play
them too I've got links in the
description so without further ado let's
turn down the lights and get stuck at
number 6 I've got the cell in this game
you have to find items and come up with
creative ways to use them to progress
what's super creepy about the game
though isn't just the location ambient
noise but the fact that your character
only speaks backwards and whenever you
get a phone call it sounds like this
turn to 350 to show you a huge number 5
these next few games are point and click
games mostly ones where you have to find
a way to escape first the house or this
one is really mysterious and fumble
around and clicking on different things
seeing what happens and hoping to make
sense of all the strange clues for
instance clicking certain people in this
creepy drawing causes things to
momentarily change the only thing that's
really clear right off the bat is that
something very terrible happened here
number 4 ex mortis this point-and-click
also puts you in a terrifying house one
that you find yourself in after waking
up for reasons unknown in the middle of
the woods the artwork and music are
super creepy and it's fun to poke around
hmm nothing in the cabinets but what
about this microwave dripping blood let
me just open it real quick the same guy
behind ex mortis also made number three
purgatorium this game is about figuring
out how to escape from a room while also
learning about the dark event that
occurred in it as always be sure to look
really closely at number two we leave
the point-and-click adventures for
bright in the screen what's creepy about
this online game is the fact that you
learn the rules as you play and usually
only moments before it's too late you
have to avoid the crazy red guys and
click black boxes to see what
beyond if you don't you might be
surprised by what's there or not there
and at number one is a game I'm really
impressed by a closure in this game the
plains face is completely dark except
for the light coming from a globe you
carry around the artwork is fantastic
and really twisted great for playing in
the dark but here's what's super cool
anything not touched by your light
doesn't exist you can use this to your
advantage and hop through walls or fall
through floors that the light made real
so there you go six online flash games
to put you in the Halloween spirit that
you can play right now for free in your
browser go ahead the links are in the
description play them in the meantime
leave a comment below about what you are
going to dress as for Halloween don't
tell anyone because it's kind of a
secret but me personally I think I'm
gonna go as wheezywaiter
as always thank you so much for watching
be sure to subscribe for more and I'll
see you later
[Applause]
[Music]
you